the Budweiser thing here has has been
instructive because yeah Budweiser loses
six and a half billion in market cap
they could have gotten that back if they
would just shut up it's unbelievable
they keep changing their story every
single day but I should apologize it's
very they can apologize but initially
they defended it then they tried to
pretend they didn't know about it then
they tried to split the baby with this
crisis communication stuff then they
made that stupid horse commercial that
appealed to nobody and so they keep
blowing it here but the bigger story I
think is not even the the hit to
Anheuser-Busch I think the bigger story
is the hit to Dylan Mulvaney's brand
because I'm not convinced after this
huge unprecedented blowback against Bud
Light do you think other companies are
going to be so quick to sponsor this guy